hello everyone a very important event in
chess history took place in New York
from 15 December til 2nd of January and
for those of you who don't know which
event this was it was actually the
United States Chess Championship and
this is the sixth time Bobby Fischer
played the US chess championship and he
won the five previous time times that he
participated so this is his sixth time
participating and this time he won this
event which eleven points out of eleven
games so he had a perfect score in the
end and after this tournament whenever
anyone anywhere wins the tournament with
a perfect score they just say he won the
tournament with Fischer's result and
everyone knows what they are talking
about so it was you know quite an
annihilation of the field
aside from Fischer there were like there
were six other grandmasters there three
international masters and to untitled
players in this tournament and Fischer
crushed them all so this is a game from
round six of this tournament of course
he won the previous five and it's quite
a beauty it's a 17 move miniature and I
decided not only to show you the game
but I will also have a question for you
at the end of the game the question will
be why did black resign Fischer's
opponent at this game
is Robert Henrich nightmare and I
couldn't find a picture of him I'm sorry
a photo of him that's why there's a
hoodie guy there instead of Robert but I
did find out that he was a he was
actually a very strong player right at
somewhere around 24 fifty plus and he
won the he won the st. Louis state
championship when he was 15 years old so
definitely a strong player 24 50 plus in
those days was quite a lot so let's see
this game Fischer has the white pieces
and I actually think that Fischer didn't
think for one second while playing this
game I actually think that fish were
actually just nudists from theory and
it's a caro-kann game probably if you're
a con player you might want to check
this game out as this position might
actually happen on the board in one of
your own games okay so let's see it
Fischer goes for efore that goes
thing we have c6 by Robert the caro-kann
defense d4 d5 now Knight to c3 D
captures Knight captures Bishop to f5
and the knight to g3 attacking the
bishop pushing it back this is the
classical variation of the caro-kann all
is well
Bishop to g6 and we have Knight to f3
nice to f6 and only now H for H sixths
making room for the bishop on h7 Bishop
to d3 now Bishop captures Queen captures
and we have E six official plays Bishop
to b2 Knight B to d7 and a queenside
castle by Fischer Queen to c7 we have c4
now and a queen sized castle also by
Robert bishop the c3 enforcing this pawn
and also preparing to bring the rook
into the game so this will probably
finish development for white then then
it'll be time to time to choose a plan
and here Robert gets a very interesting
idea
he wants to activate all of his pieces
instantly and it seems like it's a
pretty good plan but Fischer shows why
it doesn't work
Henry here plays Robert Henry sorry
Queen to f4 check and if you block this
you can block it of course with Queen
III or Queen D Queen d2 but Fischer
doesn't want to trade Queens if you play
something like Bishop to d2 Robert can
also go back Queen c7 now we have an
awkwardly placed bishop on D - if you
fly back you can always go with Queen f4
check again but after this Queen to f4
checker fish simply plays kink the b1
we have Knight the c5 now attacking the
Queen the pawn can't capture it's pinned
the Rockville grab the Queen and we have
Queen to c2 and this is actually a
brilliant move as the Fisher knows of
what Robert is trying to do if if he
played something like Queenie 3 blocking
it getting out of the way then after
Queen captures F captures black and
simply play Bishop to d6 if you capture
my knight I'll capture your knight
this will be a better position for black
so after this night the c5 Fischer
calmly plays Queen to c2 and here comes
Knight to e4 Knight c3
or and there is a threat here of night
captures an F - if this knight on f3
ever moves but that's exactly what
Fisher does Fisher plays Knight to e5
and here Robert has has something to
solve why is Fisher offering him the f2
pawn of course if Knight captured this
will for both Roxy will win the exchange
the only thing you have to be careful
about is the Fisher place rook to f1
well either rope to f1 this will pin
your knight
but if this happens you can simply
capture the night on g3 as there will no
longer be upon an f2 the guard the g3
night so it seems like like it's settled
Robert decides he will capture the pawn
he plays Knight captures on f2 Forks the
rooks and in this position Fischer
played rook be to f1 and here in this
position Robert Henry Steinmeier also
resigned the game now it's very
interesting before in this position you
consider whether you capture the pawn
and it's pretty clear if rope to f1 you
grab the night all is well if rook
doesn't come to f1 then you will win the
exchange and again all is well but as he
decided to capture it Fischer played
rugby to f1 and Robert resigned the game
in this position so this is the position
I want you to really check out I want
you to enjoy it and I want you to tell
me in the comments why did Robert resign
in this position what's the idea why is
this position so terrible for black so
yeah that's the game this is around 6
from of the United States Championship
1963-1964 that Fischer won with a
beautiful result of 11th 11 points out
of 11 games I do hope you enjoyed it and
for those of you who are able to solve
it quick quickly don't write the
solution in the comment just write solve
it or hash tags all that or anything but
give the other the other players also
also a chance to solve solve it on their
own so as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I think all for
watching this
amazing game and I will see soon